[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'élection à l'unanimité de Monsieur
tente au poste de secrétaire général
permanent des Nations Unies aura surpris
et soulagé à la fois l'Union soviétique
abandonnait ainsi son projet antérieur
de troïka et du même coup cette élection
qui consacrait le rôle de médiateur de
Monsieur tende dans l'affaire de Cuba
est apparu comme un signe de détente
entre l'Est et l'Ouest
[Musique]
le maréchal Tito est décidé de passer
ses vacances en Union soviétique et que
Monsieur krokchaf soit venu l'accueillir
lui et son épouse au milieu de tous les
honneurs est aussi le signe d'une autre
détente après une brouille de six ans la
glace semble bien rompue entre Moscou et
Belgrade
et que ce geste de Monsieur crotchev
s'est produit au moment même où le
maréchal Tito était l'objet de violentes
critique de la Chine
[Applaudissements]
devant des milliers de allendais venus
de toutes les régions du pays les
funérailles solennelles de la princesse
willemins se sont déroulés à d'elle la
princesse will el mine avait insisté
pour que tout se passe le plus
simplement possible la reine Juliana et
les princesses étaient en blanc et le
Roi Baudouin et la reine Fabiola cachait
mal leur émotion
toute une nation pleurait en rendant un
dernier hommage à cette reine qui oser
les plus sombres de l'histoire des
Pays-Bas avait soutenu son peuple avec
un courage simple et une fois
inébranlable
[Musique]
devant les 2000 paires conciliaires
réunis à Saint-Pierre de Rome Jean 23 à
clos la première session du concile
écumelique
le travail ne s'arrêtera pas déclarer le
pape une tâche d'une grande importance
nous attendent encore Rome retrouvera en
effet les pères venus des quatre coins
du monde en septembre 1963
[Musique]
en France l'installation de la deuxième
assemblée de la Cinquième République à
ranimer les traits de l'hémicycle du
Palais Bourbon
[Musique]
la réélection au fauteuil de président
de Monsieur Chaban-Delmas ne faisait de
doutes pour personne mais les 287
suffrages qui allaient se porter sur son
nom devait permettre d'évaluer la
majorité gouvernementale
le lendemain devait apporter l'image du
nouveau gouvernement réuni pour un
premier Conseil des ministres autour du
général de Gaulle une image assez peu
différente de celle du précédent puisque
le ministère Pompidou n'a subi que
quelques remaniements et ne comprend que
trois nouveaux venus
[Musique]
à Tours 8e journée internationale du
film de court-métrage au programme sans
film de 21 nations le Grand Prix que
devait remettre Monsieur Michel foret
Cormeray directeur du Centre du Cinéma
est allé au réalisateur polonais Roman
Polanski pour son film les mammifères
Pierrelatte c'est toi le distacé c'est
un coin de Provence bien que proche de
la Nationale 7 on aurait pu croire cette
cité vouée à sommeiller à l'ombre de son
clocher avec ses petites ruées son
unique facteur
or voici qu'il y a 4 ans le Commissariat
à l'énergie atomique choisi Pierrelatte
pour y installer son usine de séparation
des isotopes
70k franchissent aujourd'hui chaque jour
le contrôle sévère de l'usinatomique
pour y amener 3000 ouvriers ils seront 5
ou 6000 en 1967 réaction en chaîne si
l'on peut dire des entreprises
satellites s'édifient dans le voisinage
[Musique]
si bien que le maire de Pierrelatte
s'apprête à compter dans 5 ans 20 000
administrés alors qu'il n'en n'avait que
3448 en 1954 dès à présent la vie du
chef-lieu de canton de la Drôme en é
bouleversé les bancs ont déjà pris
position
tous les boutiques ont rajeuni où sont
en train de le faire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tandis qu'on apprécie déjà les plaisirs
des grandes villes
s'ensuit
stationnement réglementé etc etc
l'ancienne poste c'est doublé d'un
bâtiment provisoire où les demoiselles
du téléphone affrontent maintenant un
standard de l'importance de celui d'une
ville comme Montélimar
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
quantum facteur on la multiplié par 5 et
personne ne chauffe
c'est que le paysage a sensiblement
changé des immeubles de 15 étages et ont
poussé comme des champignons et ce n'est
pas fini l'usine atomique a changé le
destin de Pierrelatte mais Pierrelatte
plus qu'un exemple c'est l'image même
d'un État qui se veut moderne en
édifiant aujourd'hui sa propre industrie
atomique
[Musique]
un anniversaire vient de passer inaperçu
le centenaire du chapeau melon il est
vrai qu'on ne le porte plus guère
aujourd'hui sur les Champs-Élysées et
quand on le porte
pourtant lorsqu'il y a 100 ans à un
chapelier londonien eu confectionné pour
un gentleman farmer du nom de William
coq le couvre chez inédit le monde
entier l'adapta danshousiasme du moins
le monde portant moustache
il faut avouer que le melon apportait ce
je ne sais quoi qui manquait encore pour
faire d'un homme ordinaire le Conquérant
sur de lui
les premiers chasseurs d'images le
coiffeur
il fut de tous les duels célèbres
[Musique]
la foule l'arborat comme le signe
visible de sa bonne conscience et l'on
ne vit jamais sans doute hommage si bien
rendu à l'exemple de Clémenceau les
hommes politiques l'adoptèrent
avec Aristide Briand il présida ainsi au
destiné de la France comme un symbole
rassurant il devint même si banal qu'une
certaine police le portait pour passer
inaperçu
et puis il arrive à ce qu'il devait
arriver les foules versatiles le Renière
pour le chapeau mou d'abord pour les
têtes nues en Suisse c'était dans la fin
non pourtant il reste à fidèlement
révéler sur les champs de course
de lointaines expéditions lancées vers
un Pérou inconnu le trouvèrent au détour
du chemin sur des têtes de femmes
[Applaudissements]
les Frères Jacques l'inclure dans leur
silhouette
et voici qu'aujourd'hui la mode il
revient mais cette fois ce sont les
femmes qui s'en sont un par
nez voici 100 ans le chapeau melon vient
de retrouver ainsi un regain de gloire
mais que durera t-il le temps d'un
caprice sans doute
[Musique]
si les bijoux sont de tous les temps
Vulcain déjà travaillé pour les dieux
chaque époque a eu son style dans son
atelier parisien Jean-Claude Champagnat
est un des créateurs d'aujourd'hui qu'il
faut placer à la pointe de lavangarde
entre ses mains naissent non des bijoux
fantaisie mais des bijoux qui ont un
impacter une fantaisie folle on ne
s'étendra pas de les voir passer tour à
tour du figuratif à l'abstrait
feuille d'or ciselée grenat c'est une
bague qui s'inspire prosaïquement du
fruit du mûrier
[Musique]
la nuit étoilé a inspiré cet
architecture d'or et de corail
fleurs d'émeraude sur fond
[Musique]
lac blanche or et rubis une bague russe
née à Paris
mais ce n'est pas tout on peut dire que
l'oeuvre de Jean-Claude Champagnat qui
est à la fois de l'art floral issu de
l'École de Nancy et des mobiles de
Calder
[Musique]
des bagues vertigineuses en somme et
dont certaines mettront à votre doigt
mesdames la marque de notre temps
atomique et spatial
[Musique]